[MUSIC PLAYING]
RETO MEIER: Hi there,
and welcome back
to the Next Live Show.
I'm Reto Meier.
STEPHANIE WONG: And
I'm Stephanie Wong.
It's our last day together
here at Google Cloud Next '19.
These past few days
have been a whirlwind
of product announcements,
demos, experiments,
and inspirational
stories from people
who are dedicated to making
the cloud better for everyone.
RETO MEIER: And to
help with that mission,
we've made all that content
easily accessible to you
a g.co/nextonair.
There, you'll find videos of
everything we've live streamed
and recorded at Next, including
the keynotes, all the breakout
sessions and fireside chats, and
all the Next Live Show demos,
special interviews with Google
Cloud leaders, and more.
It's all on demand for
you to watch and share.
STEPHANIE WONG:
You still have time
to check out the
other five channels
of Next Live programming,
organized by themes--
Build, Run, Analyze and Learn,
Secure, and Collaborate.
RETO MEIER: We're joined now by
Adam Seligman, vice president
of developer relations.
Now, I love the theme of
last night's keynote--
Get To The Fun Part.
Can you talk a little bit
about how you chose that theme,
and why you feel it resonates
with our develop and, really,
all technical practitioners?
ADAM SELIGMAN: Yeah, you bet.
Thanks for having me.
It's exciting to be here.
The key note was super
fun, and the whole idea
was to really celebrate what
developers and operators
actually do every day.
Hopefully, they're
spending hours a day
productively, building apps,
running apps, deploying apps,
monitoring apps, and not
dealing with all the other stuff
that you normally have to do
when you build applications,
especially in the enterprise.
Getting out of waterfall
and getting to agile,
not just throwing over--
an app over the wall for
someone else to operate,
but taking ownership in a
DevOps culture and operating.
And really removing
all the barriers,
everything from not having to
manage and shard databases, not
have to manually manage your
VMs, or even pick VM sizes,
and really just get to the
heart of building applications,
and then let the cloud
take care of it from there.
That was the spirit we wanted
to capture in the keynote.
STEPHANIE WONG: So configuring
networks, rewriting apps due
to cloud provider changes,
and waiting around for build,
test, and deploy are
clearly not the fun parts.
Didn't Google once face
these sort of issues?
And how were we able to
remedy that at such scale?
ADAM SELIGMAN: Google has
built a lot of great software
to run these services
that billions of people
use every day, so a lot of--
a couple of decades
of experience
went into how do we help Google
developers become incredibly
productive so they
can spend an hour--
six hours on average of
writing software every day
and absolutely
minimize everything
else in the chain of
getting to deployment
and getting that service
out to production where
a small number of users can
test it as a canary deployment
and start giving you feedback.
So we're trying to build
that into our cloud.
We've seen the rise of DevOps
practices out in the industry,
but now we're building
into our products,
with products like Cloud
Code, like Managed Kubernetes,
and CSP, Cloud Run, our
new serverless offering.
Just really reducing
the barriers anyone,
like a Google engineer,
can build code
and get it into production
as easily as possible.
RETO MEIER: Fantastic.
Now, if you had to pick just
one, just one best practice
from yesterday's keynote that
you want developers to walk
away with, what would it be?
ADAM SELIGMAN: I'm
going to cheat a little,
and instead of a
thing Google said,
I really like what
Twinkle Desai said,
who is a VP at Kohl's,
who started her career
as a developer and
a Unix sysadmin,
and she built a lot of
automation at Kohl's.
Now, she runs-- a
couple years later,
she runs a 200 person team.
They have a 100 microservices,
5,000 containers.
It's all automated.
It's running on
managed GKE On-Prem.
She said they've been through
two big holiday shopping
windows, which in retail
is a really big deal.
So I'm thrilled
that Google Cloud
can support retail customers.
But by making her
people super productive,
it's been really great for
Kohl's and really great
for her career.
STEPHANIE WONG: And that's an
inspirational customer story.
We also saw incredible demos
during the keynote yesterday.
Can you tell us
about some of them,
and which one was your favorite?
ADAM SELIGMAN: There was a
couple that were a lot of fun.
I really like what Wix is
doing with Google Cloud.
They've gone from being a
drag and drop web environment,
but now it's
totally programmable
and extensible Google Cloud.
That's really exciting.
The opening demo that Mandy
[INAUDIBLE] let us through,
her dev team is
taking us through,
was very, very
cool because it was
a mix of developers doing
VM-based development
with Jenkins for
deployment of new VM
images, a container-based
app in the middle,
and then extending the new
services with functions,
serverless functions,
which was pretty cool.
So to see all those teams
working together and using
tools like Cloud Code, our new
IDE integration for VS Code
and IntelliJ, just awesome.
People can work the
way they want to work.
It all works together.
All runs in Google
Cloud seamlessly.
One pane of glass
with Stackdriver
to observe and manage it,
and I think it's great.
Let developers do what they
want and get to the fun parts.
STEPHANIE WONG:
That's fantastic.
Thank you so much again for
joining us today and giving us
some of that great information.
RETO MEIER: And let's check
in with Joanna for a closer
look at the network
postcard experiment,
and to understand
why speed matters.
JOANNA SMITH: Hi, I'm in
the Dev Zone once again,
but now I'm with
Terrence Ryan, who
one of my favorite co-workers.
I'm not going to lie about that.
So this demo in particular--
it's a digital postcard.
Is that right?
TERRY RYAN: Yeah,
that's kind of the idea.
The idea is you take
a selfie or picture,
and we will bounce it around
our network, our private network
all around the world and
print it out for you.
So the pictures that
you get over here
are pictures that have traveled
around the world digitally.
JOANNA SMITH: Oh,
my gosh, and so
that's what these stamps are.
Each data--
TERRY RYAN: Each data center--
each data center, we
have a stamp for it,
and it doesn't stamp it until
it's in that data center.
JOANNA SMITH: Now, when you
talk about a private network,
you mean the actual
physical cables
and data centers that Google
built around the world.
TERRY RYAN: Yeah,
exactly, the same data
centers and same infrastructure
that powers Search
and Mail also, under
the covers, it's
available to Google
Cloud customers
as their private network.
So whenever you talk between
one machine and another machine
on Google Cloud, it's always
traveling on our network.
It never leaves the
network, and so you
get much better
performance in terms
of being able to
communicate and security,
because it's not leaving.
It's not on the public internet.
JOANNA SMITH: Oh, my
gosh, this is actually
one of my favorite facts
about Google Cloud.
It's a fun fact, which is
we built an infrastructure
to power our Search, and then
we started opening that up
to other people
so that you don't
have to reinvent the wheel.
But it's really important
that we make it easy to use.
Was this pretty easy to set up?
TERRY RYAN: Absolutely.
One of the great things
about Google Cloud's default
networking in our projects,
is if all the machines
are in the same
project, all the VMs--
the VMs are what are powering
the relaying and stamping here.
If they're all in
the same project,
then they are automatically
wired to talk to one another
without the developer
having to do any work
to make that happen.
And so what that
allows you to do
is get started without having
to set up VPNs and VPCs to get
all that working.
All of that is done for you.
All the routing is done for you.
And if you want, this is
an open-source project,
so you can actually pull
down and see how we set it up
and see that it really
is that super simple.
JOANNA SMITH: And I like that it
makes it accessible to someone
who might not have
that networking
experience or
background, but so long
as they can
understand the theory,
they can actually get going.
TERRY RYAN: Yeah, exactly.
JOANNA SMITH: This
is so exciting.
I love this demo.
I am so happy to
take all my photos,
and more importantly, the
fact that it is open source
means that anyone at
home can play along
even if you don't get to have
your own cute photo to take
home.
And I hope you all have
a great time, and thanks
for joining me in the Dev Zone.
RETO MEIER: Great job, team.
The next session
is about to begin,
so we'll see you right back
here in less than an hour
for a deep dive
discussion on APIs
with Amit Zavery, VP of
engineering at Apigee.
Then we'll head back to our
showcase for more demos.
Stick around.
You're watching the Next
Live Show from San Francisco.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Welcome back to
the Next Live Show.
I'm Reto Meier.
STEPHANIE WONG: And
I'm Stephanie Wong
here with Amit Zavery, VP of
engineering, to dive into APIs.
Welcome, and thanks
for joining us.
AMIT ZAVERY: Sure,
thanks for having me.
STEPHANIE WONG:
So I want to talk
about APIs, which
have come a long way
from the software interfaces
popularized by Win32 APIs.
Tell us where they are today,
and your predictions for APIs
in 2019 and where Apigee
lies in this space.
AMIT ZAVERY: Sure, sure.
I think if you look at what's
going on in the industry today,
there are many things
which are driving
the modernization of a lot
of existing applications.
So APIs are becoming
the front end
to a lot of the
assets companies have
already in their
portfolio, and they unlock
a lot of those content for
different kind of users,
be it end users, be it
partners, as well as employees.
So I think, if we look
at going forward in 2019,
you'll start seeing a lot of
different ways of exposing
those APIs.
One, a lot of
companies are using,
trying to monetize on
them to be able to use
that to create a
lot of new content
as well as partnerships.
So we have a lot of good
examples of customers,
say "Magazine Luisa"
in Brazil, who
is trying to create a lot of
e-commerce kind of content
and be able to expose a lot of
data to the end user to buy it.
Same thing with
AccuWeather, where
they want to be able to now
take a lot of the weather data
and share it and make it
available to a lot of other end
users as well.
So that's one driving factor.
Second thing is popularization
of a lot of ways of interfacing
through voice and text.
So you see bots.
You see, of course, a different
kind of consumer devices,
and that requires
a lot of interfaces
into the back end systems
and be able to expose it
through voice and text.
So that's also driving
a lot of interest
from companies to be able to
use API management for that.
And third area, we've seen
a lot of driving factor,
and you'll see a lot of
it as we move forward,
is a lot of industry
requirements.
So there's a lot of open
standards coming out,
a lot of regulations coming
out, and APIs is the one way
to log the content and
make sure they're secured
and they are available
to the right people.
So that's another
complete new requirement
we're seeing and becoming very
popular as we move forward.
RETO MEIER: That's exciting.
Now, obviously, a lot of APIs
that drive ecosystems are
publicly visible, but many of
the APIs at any given company
are only used internally.
How does Apigee support
both of those use cases?
AMIT ZAVERY: Sure.
So I think the way we have
built our platform at--
in the Apigee area
was to really make
sure that anybody who
wants to expose APIs,
we provide them ways to
manage the whole process,
be it internal or
external users.
And so the platform is really
kind of agnostic of that fact,
but we, of course, provide a
lot of safeguarding when it's
externally exposed, a lot of
the right kind of regulations,
the right kind of permissions,
security elements are built in.
Similarly inside,
when you're trying
to expose it inside
the enterprise,
and be able to use it
between different employees
for different
application development,
again, we provide the whole
lifecycle management for it.
So there are a lot of,
again, capabilities
for a developer to
use and leverage
when they're building
those applications,
and they can decide the
roles and how and what
is to be shared, and a lot
of features kind of build
into really make that happen.
STEPHANIE WONG: And
a lot of companies
are now looking
towards microservices,
but microservices
will continue to have
a lot of different recipes.
Successful microservice
architecture
is complex to design,
build, and manage,
and there are a lot of
experimentation going on.
But the key is to build
reusable decoupled services that
can scale with the right
levels of governance.
How is Apigee helping to support
microservice architecture?
AMIT ZAVERY: I
think, general, the--
if you look at the architecture
evolution in general,
it's idea is to really have
a small kind of services
and decoupled in a way.
And the best way to use those
services is through an API.
So what Apigee does is,
now that we have interfaces
to a lot of the microservices
management layer--
for example, Istio, which
Google provides us a service,
allows you to now expose
those microservices,
manage them in a
much better way,
and orchestrate and do a
lot of monitoring around it.
And what we do with Apigee
is we integrate with Istio
and really provide the
ability to manage those APIs
through one of those--
one way.
Otherwise, if you have other
microservices, you have an API,
we can, of course, manage
that lifecycle for that
and allow you to use
those microservices
in a much better fashion than
a monolithic application would
be.
RETO MEIER: Nice.
Can you talk a little bit about
the new general availability
releases of Apigee
Edge for private cloud?
AMIT ZAVERY: Yeah,
I think, the way
we're looking at
Apigee in general
is to have a deployment
model which is flexible.
So one is to be
able to, of course,
you can continue
using it on prem.
Second thing is to be able
to now take it in the cloud.
We have an Apigee Edge product
is available in the cloud
as well, fully
managed by Google.
Third is this hybrid
mechanism, where
you can have some of the runtime
running anywhere you choose, be
it private cloud or on premise.
You can be running
on Kubernetes or GKE.
And the control plane
is running in the cloud,
and that could be in any cloud.
Could be Google or any
third party cloud as well.
So we try to make sure the
architecture is very flexible,
giving choices to the
customers and developers
to really deploy the way they
would want to, and specifically
with Edge, we do provide a
private cloud edition where you
can run on GKE, and
GKE On-Premise can
be available anywhere
the developer want
to choose to deploy it.
And we allow you to
have it very easy,
and easy to manage
and easy to deploy.
So I mean, that's
available today,
and we continue to make
progress in that area.
STEPHANIE WONG: It's exciting.
So we know that
APIs and building
APIs isn't just enough.
You have to actually convince
your developers to use them,
and that means developer
portals become key.
How does Apigee's developer
portal and its enhancements
help that happen?
AMIT ZAVERY: Yeah, I think,
to tie everything together,
you have to have a structure
where this information can
be available.
So the developers,
of course, would
love to have one way in terms
of how you manage the APIs,
but how do you expose it
to a developer portal?
So Apigee provides a
lot of capabilities
on the developer portal site.
So we have a customer facing
portal, a partner facing
portal, all the
lifecycle for getting
your APIs into the
portal as well,
all the services
that are available.
The developer doesn't have to
do a lot of the heavy lifting
in terms of how to
share that content, how
to get the right kind
of security around it.
So the developer
portal, today, is
available through
all of our products,
and we keep on making
enhancements to it.
There's one offering
through Drupal, as well,
to a third party
CMS if a customer
chooses to use heavy duty portal
and has a lot more capabilities
for a lot of specific
things, custom
work you might want to do.
But we also have an
integrated portal as part
of our offering today, which
is very simple, easy to use,
and you can create
a lot of interface--
portal interfaces for end
users very quickly and easily.
RETO MEIER: That's great.
Apigee is built on
best practice to help
create world-class
developer experiences,
so tell me a little bit about--
a little bit more about that.
AMIT ZAVERY: I think,
in general, I think--
just not Apigee.
If you look at
Google, we've been
trying to make sure the
Google Cloud make developer
experience very
friendly, and I think
one of the key things
for a developer
is the lifecycle of how do
you create an application
and deliver that.
And the one big part of that
is the API management for it,
in terms of the whole
lifecycle, and so
we have made sure,
for a developer,
it's very easy to onboard.
They can start writing an API.
They can start documenting
it, testing it, and design
and delivering it.
So we provide a lot of
tooling for that, very simple,
easy to use, and what we've
been doing beyond that is really
how now kind of
giving you metering,
monitoring, monetization.
So now, we have an
idea who's using what,
what kind of security you
have, what kind of privileges
were provided to that user,
as well as what kind of usage
you got out of it and how much
money you can make out of it,
so you have a lot of that
data available to you
at your fingertips.
So we've been doing a
lot of work to really add
a lot of this value add beyond
just being able to build an API
and deliver it, but
also all the things
you needed on monitoring,
metering, security,
monetization.
So that's really becoming
a very powerful element
into the feature capabilities
for developers and anybody
else who's going
to do this work.
STEPHANIE WONG: Thank
you so much, Amit.
We've packed a lot of info
into our talk, so thanks
for your time.
AMIT ZAVERY: Thanks
for having me.
STEPHANIE WONG: If you've got a
question or a comment on APIs,
be sure to reach out to us on
social media with the hashtag
#GoogleNext19.
RETO MEIER: Now, let's
head back to our showcase
for a look at more demos.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: We're here in the
Customer Magic neighborhood
with a pretty impressive booth
here with NASA and James,
the director of NASA FDL.
JAMES PARR: Yeah, I am.
I'm the-- NASA FDL is an applied
AI research lab for NASA.
It's a public-private
partnership, which is great,
so it means we can ask corporate
partners of experts in AI
to help us with our problems.
SPEAKER: So with that in
mind, how does Google Cloud
and NASA FDL work together?
JAMES PARR: Well, we
had a big problem,
and the problem
was are we alone,
which is kind of the big one.
And we knew that you
like big problems,
so we thought, well,
hey, we'll call up Google
and see if they can help us.
What's interesting
about this problem
is we have scientists who are
fantastic at understanding
the problem, and enormous data--
data, you can't
imagine how big is it.
SPEAKER: Just--
JAMES PARR: Huge, and so really,
we needed a corporate expert
like Google to help us.
What we prototyped
with Google Cloud,
with FDL, is the sort of
relationships and sort
of partnerships
which NASA's going
to need if we're going
to be putting people
on the moon in five years.
So it's really-- if
you like, we kind of,
a toe in the water about how the
future should be, just in terms
of the way we're
solving problems,
the way we're partnering.
That's what we've been
prototyping with you guys,
and that's really what
Google's amazing at.
And I have to say thank you
for the help you guys have
given because we did it.
We've done some really
extraordinary work here.
And I think Massi's
going to take us
through some of the
fragments of what was done,
and this is what you can
come and see at this booth.
We're very proud of
the work, and just
like to say, thanks, again.
SPEAKER: Oh, of course.
I mean, it's great to hear.
It's super exciting to see
this kind of really turn to,
what can we actually do
with this technology?
How do we help people?
And so we're going to
walk through and see
what people here at Next can
kind of get their hands on
and experiment with, and
then also see, how does that
help us answer, are we alone?
JAMES PARR: Yeah,
the team have done
a great job of taking
something really complex
and making really simple,
and you can have a go
and play with light curves
and finding exoplanets.
So there's some
really cool stuff
to get your hands
on here as well.
SPEAKER: Awesome.
Let's take a look.
JAMES PARR: Yeah, awesome.
SPEAKER: So we just
talked to James
about how the partnership
between NASA FDL and Google
Cloud helped enable
scientists to really start
doing this analysis.
What can people here
at Next actually play
with to see what
that looks like?
MASSIMO MASCARO:
Yeah, absolutely.
So the challenge was grandiose--
finding life on other planets.
So how do you break
it down in steps?
So step one, you have to
find other planets that
are outside the solar system.
So we actually worked on
that challenge to start with,
and what you can see here is a
little bit of a representation
of how that works.
So here, you have one
of these light curves,
and the task here you can do is
actually try to classify by eye
is this a planet or not.
So as you can see, actually,
it's a quite hard task.
You have to understand when
things are planet or not,
and there are actually
a lot of subtleties.
Here, this takes, actually,
a lot of human labor,
and a lot of astrophysics
minds actually spent
on this for years.
So what we have as an idea
is that can we actually
have machine learning
help us with this?
And so we use actually
the power of deep learning
and AI in Google Cloud to
train a model that does this.
So the researchers did this,
actually, with our technology,
and actually, they were able
to get a model that is not only
more accurate than
humans, it can actually
process entire data sets
in minutes, where before it
actually took years.
SPEAKER: So people
can kind of see
the details of why it was
so important to have machine
learning to help out the human
knowledge that was required
to make this happen.
MASSIMO MASCARO: Absolutely.
SPEAKER: So for
those exoplanets,
can we take a look at those
in the mobile apps over there?
MASSIMO MASCARO:
Yeah, so here we
have a very simple
app that you can
use to kind of scan
the sky, and there are
a lot of planets in the sky.
And once you point at
one of those planets,
you can actually
study it, and you
would get the composition of
the atmosphere of that planet.
So this actually is more
kind of a gamified version
of this that represents
why is this so important.
SPEAKER: So this is a cool
way to see and kind of get
a little bit of a taste
into exactly what goes
into making those
decisions and understanding
all the technology that's
required to say, look,
we're now making
these predictions.
Let's see if we can find
somewhere and actually answer,
is there life out there.
MASSIMO MASCARO: Absolutely.
And again, I mean, the beauty of
this is that a lot of this work
has been done by astrophysicists
and astronomy researchers, that
didn't have a lot of IT
knowledge or AI knowledge.
They were just powered by
both the power of computation
in Google Cloud
and by our AI tools
to answer these really,
really hard questions.
SPEAKER: Right,
it lets them focus
on what's important to them,
and the technology just
helps enable it.
MASSIMO MASCARO: Absolutely.
SPEAKER: That's awesome.
Thanks so much.
MASSIMO MASCARO: Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
NATALIE PIUCCO: Hi, everyone.
My name's Natalie, and we are
in the G Suite demo booth.
And I'm joined here
by Rickard, who's
from Gant, a customer who had an
amazing digital transformation
with G Suite.
Welcome.
RICKARD SODERBERG: Thank you.
Thank you very much.
NATALIE PIUCCO: Tell us
a little bit about Gant
and how you opened up a
new store with G Suite
in three months.
Amazing.
RICKARD SODERBERG: So
Gant is a fashion brand.
We're have our headquarters
in Stockholm today.
We're an old company.
Was actually born in
USA from the beginning.
One of the things that we
did is we brought the button
down shirt to the market.
NATALIE PIUCCO: That's amazing.
Fun fact.
RICKARD SODERBERG: Yeah.
So a couple of years ago,
we had a challenge where
we had to open up a new store
on Regent Street in London,
and we had a record amount--
we had to do it in a
record amount time.
So we-- what usually
takes one year,
we had to do in three months.
NATALIE PIUCCO: Oh, my goodness,
so you needed to work fast.
RICKARD SODERBERG:
We had to work fast.
NATALIE PIUCCO: So we've
actually got Whitney here
as well, who's going to
take us through a demo.
Is that right?
RICKARD SODERBERG:
That is correct.
WHITNEY: Here, we have a
cool video of the London
store actually being
built out by the team,
and as they were
planning, they had a lot
of documents going around.
They needed to be
able to get everyone
on the same page working
on the same document,
moving quickly together.
And so they used to send
file versions back and forth
all the time, and it really
slowed down the process.
So they switched to Google
Docs, and using Google Docs,
they were all able
to work together
on the same document in
all of the different teams
across their locations.
And they were able to
comment each other in,
to assign tasks,
get inputs from team
members across all
different locations,
and able to just really
move quickly together
because they were all running
in that same document.
And we're going to move now
from our London store team
to the Stockholm
headquarters team.
NATALIE PIUCCO: OK.
So now, you're going to show
us what the Stockholm team was
doing for inventory planning.
Right?
WHITNEY: Yes, exactly.
So we've just moved into the
Stockholm headquarters, where
the team was also working really
hard to prepare for the London
store opening, and they were
focused mostly on planning
all of the inventory
that was going
to be needed for the new store.
And so in order to do
that, they needed everyone
working on the same spreadsheet,
planning what was going on,
planning where the clothes were
coming from, how much we needed
of each item, things like that.
And the same way with
Docs, how they were all
able to collaborate live
on that one document,
they were able to
do the same thing
on the spreadsheet, which helped
them move really quickly as
well.
And they also used
a feature called
Sheets Explore, which allows
people to ask questions
about their data in
natural language,
so they can get insights
from their data,
like what's the average
price per quantity and things
like that.
And that way,
they're able to get
all the information they need
to plan really effectively.
NATALIE PIUCCO: But through
actually asking, through voice,
those types of questions--
it's awesome because a lot
of people--
businesses don't
necessarily know
how to write SQL
or complex queries.
The Sheets Explore tool
is amazing for that.
WHITNEY: Yeah, no longer do we
have the headaches of creating
all the pivot tables
by hand, but rather you
can just go in and get those
insights from your data
right away.
NATALIE PIUCCO: Great.
OK.
Now, we're going to imagine
we're in another country.
WHITNEY: We've made
it to Portugal,
where the Gant manufacturing
facility is located.
NATALIE PIUCCO: A
quick trip to Portugal.
WHITNEY: Quick trip.
RICKARD SODERBERG: Quick trip.
WHITNEY: And so the team
here was working really
hard to create all
of the clothing
that was going to be
needed for the store,
and so they were hard at work
in the manufacturing facility,
really, to make the
best items they could.
But they needed to get
approvals from the London
and the Stockholm teams,
who were doing the designs
and wanted to make sure it was
the quality they were looking
for and things like that.
NATALIE PIUCCO: And
sometimes, those decisions
just need to be
made face to face.
Don't they?
WHITNEY: Yeah, exactly,
and so the Gant team
used to fly people to the
manufacturing facilities
to check out the clothing,
make sure it all looked good.
But now, they've really
switched to using
Meet, which is G Suite's
video conferencing solution.
And using Meet, they're able to
get everyone in the same room
virtually so they can
still see the look
and the feel of the clothing.
And so now, I'm actually
going to have the opportunity
to show you how
they would do that.
So we're already hooked in to
this meeting on our computer,
and I'm going to show you how
the team in the manufacturing
facility is able to join with
one click from the phone.
And then they actually
walk around with the phone
and join the meeting and be
able to see the clothing,
and get a feel for it, and this
way, get all of the approvals
they need for the clothing.
NATALIE PIUCCO: Amazing.
So it's-- you get the
feeling that you're actually
in [INAUDIBLE],, although
you're in Stockholm or London.
WHITNEY: Yes.
NATALIE PIUCCO: That's amazing.
Well, thank you so much
for this walkaround.
This has definitely been one of
the most interactive sessions
and demonstrations.
Thanks, Whitney.
WHITNEY: Yeah, no problem.
NATALIE PIUCCO: And
Rickard, also, I
guess the G Suite
technology is amazing,
but I'm assuming this just
meant so much for your customers
to be able to move from
producing a store in one
year to three months.
RICKARD SODERBERG: It did.
It was a record time, and we
ended up with happy customers.
Definitely.
NATALIE PIUCCO: I'd
imagine you did.
Thank you so much,
both, for joining us.
WHITNEY: Really appreciate it.
NATALIE PIUCCO: Thanks,
and back to you.
RETO MEIER: All
right, thanks, team.
Coming up after this next round
of sessions, a Lunch and Learn
on building amazing apps
with Cloud Firestore.
We'll have a live demo
on service monitoring
with Stackdriver.
Stay tuned.
We'll see you in about an hour.
You're watching the Next
Live Show from San Francisco.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
STEPHANIE WONG: Welcome
back to the Next Live Show.
Building the cloud for
everyone takes everyone
to create and embrace
a culture that
is inclusive and representative
of our communities.
Here at Next '19 in San
Francisco, diversity, equality,
and inclusion is
part of our DNA.
Recently, "Forbes" magazine
recognized our commitment,
naming Next as one of
the top three conferences
for women to thrive.
Let's check in with
Joanna for more
on the Inclusion
Lounge and the hashtag
#IamRemarkable workshops
happening here at Next.
JOANNA SMIITH: Thanks
so much, Stephanie.
I'm so excited to be here
at our Inclusion Lounge,
because diversity is
something that I obviously
care a lot about, but
more important than just
being diverse is making
sure that we have
multiple perspectives
at the table
so that we can build really
interesting solutions
to fun problems.
So now we're talking to Taylor,
who drives diversity, equity,
and inclusion at Next.
Hi.
TAYLOR NGUYEN: Hi, Joanna.
JOANNA SMIITH: Thank you.
This lounge is great.
You want to tell me
some fun facts about it?
TAYLOR NGUYEN: Welcome
to the Inclusion Lounge.
And the purpose of
the Inclusion Lounge
is to make sure that at Next,
we're always providing content
and experiences to support
underrepresented groups
and allies to be able
to come together, share
learnings, collaborate,
and build community.
JOANNA SMIITH: Oh my gosh, yeah.
TAYLOR NGUYEN: So yeah,
it's a safe space.
And at any time,
people could drop by,
connect with like-minded
others, get confidence coaching,
and also get headshots.
And then in the
interim, we also have
sessions like #IamRemarkable,
which is going
on right around our shoulder.
JOANNA SMIITH: I
love that session.
TAYLOR NGUYEN: Yeah.
And this session is happening
a couple times at Next.
And it takes us
through an exercise
of empowerment and learning
how to promote ourselves
in all the positive ways.
JOANNA SMIITH: What
do you think really
makes the Inclusion
Lounge stand out,
and why should people
think about coming here
during their day?
TAYLOR NGUYEN:
Yeah, you know what?
It's not even about
thinking about it.
It's just knowing
that it's available.
Because so much about
inclusion is you
have to be ready
to be in the space.
JOANNA SMIITH: Yes.
TAYLOR NGUYEN: And when
you're ready to receive
and you're ready to learn
from others and become an ally
or become an advocate, that's
the time to actually visit.
And it shouldn't be
an intimidating space.
It should be a space
where you could
feel like you could
be welcomed, you
can meet like-minded people,
and you can actually learn
and listen from one another.
Our attendees are
always sharing with us
that whether they're an
introvert or an extrovert,
they need a place to
unwind and step away
from the commotion of Next and
all the wonderful experiences
that are available here.
And then they're
really able to then go
from a collaborative
mindset rather
than an overwhelmed mindset.
JOANNA SMIITH: Thank you
again for building this space.
I really admire it.
TAYLOR NGUYEN: Thanks for
coming to talk to us about it.
And always feel that you could
drop by at the Inclusion Lounge
because we all know it's
really important at Next
to build a cloud for everyone.
Thanks, everyone.
STEPHANIE WONG: Thanks
very much, Joanna.
I'm excited to have Priyanka
Vergadia, a customer
engineer at Google
Cloud here with me
to show us how to
set up service level
monitoring in Stackdriver.
Hi, Priyanka.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Hi, Stephanie.
Thank you for having me.
STEPHANIE WONG: Thank you.
Google has published
our practices
for managing reliable
services at scale
in site reliability engineering
books and this SRE workbook.
One of the main
principles of SRE
is using service
level objectives.
Can you show us how
developers can do the same?
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Yeah,
let's dive right in and
let me show it through a demo.
STEPHANIE WONG: OK, great.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Perfect.
So I have this website here that
is built to order some stuff.
And so I'm going to put
something in the cart.
It's an e-commerce website,
so it lets you order things,
and then it places an order.
So I have my credit card
information in there,
and we just placed an order.
Now behind the scenes,
there is a lot going on
in this particular application.
So if we look at
what's going on here,
this is the service
architecture of the application.
And it is talking--
it has a front end
and has various different
services talking
to the front end, the checkout,
the catalog, the product
catalog, the card service.
There's a lot that's
going on here.
And if you see further,
they're pretty much all
written in very different
languages as well.
So there's a lot of
complexity behind the scenes
that's going on.
And this is all done through
microservices, as you can see.
So it's important to understand
that a simple website is set up
with different-- can be set
up with different services
in the back end and have
different languages that it
can be written in.
So complexities.
STEPHANIE WONG: Right.
And microservice
architectures mean
the app itself is broken
into many small pieces,
and doesn't that make
it hard to understand
how all the pieces
fit together and where
to start investigating
when there is a problem?
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
It's very-- it becomes
very hard for the
operations team,
especially in
microservices architecture,
to figure out what's going
on, which services is up,
down, talking to each other.
So there's a good tool in
Stackdriver Monitoring called
topology, where you
can actually look
at the topology of your
different microservices
talking to each other.
So I have it open here, and when
you open the service topology,
I can look at the specific
service that I'm interested in
and then see which other
services it is talking to.
So it gives me a view.
I can click on one, and it gives
me a view of what's going on
and which services
it is talking to,
which is pretty
helpful when you're
working in an
environment that has
so many different microservices
that it's talking to.
STEPHANIE WONG: Wow, and
this is great because
with microservice-based
apps, you can clearly
see the interservice
dependencies
and use that to double
check new code rollouts.
But let's say you're
setting up alerts.
Ops staff can burn
out a lot of the times
from getting notified of all the
potential causes of a problem,
making it hard to align SREs
with customer interests.
How can we identify which
behaviors really actually
matter for that service
during service degradation?
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Yeah, so there
is also another tool within
Stackdriver Monitoring
for services where you can
actually set up SLOs and define
your SLOs for the services so
operations does not actually
get affected by just looking at
all the different alerts that
can come by.
It's actually a practice
within our SRE teams
where we make sure that our
SRE stuff is only monitoring
alerts that are related to
customer issues and front end
customer-related issues and not
every single issue that might
be a cause to those issues.
So let's see that
in the demo as well.
STEPHANIE WONG: Great.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: So if
we click on Services here
in the Stackdriver monitoring.
Let's look at front end.
And when we go do that, you're
able to see the service level
optimization.
So let me click on SLOs.
And in SLOs you obviously
see nothing here.
So we're going to set one up.
And say we want to set
up for availability,
and then there is--
we can do it
rolling or calendar.
I want to say in
the month, if we
reach 99% or low availability,
then I want to get alerted.
That's a good way of
saying that you're not
going to be alerted
for everything,
but you still want to be alerted
for when we go less than 99%.
And then you can also
set up a latency alert.
So in this case,
if we say latency--
and I may want to
set up differently
for different services.
For the front end, you
could say my pages should
load in less than
1,000 milliseconds,
otherwise I want to be notified.
And in this case also,
let's say it's 90% our goal.
And then we submit that.
So these are the two
alerts that we just
set up for latency
and availability
and they are not just
thresholds because we
are saying this
percentile, so it's not
going to be chatty and noisy.
It's going to be
if this happens,
then we really want to get
notified because a service is
not working fine.
So that's a good
way of identifying
making sure that you're not
burning out your operations
staff.
STEPHANIE WONG: Excellent.
How do you follow those best
practices given the resources
that you have?
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Yeah.
So you also have metrics
and diagnostics in there.
So if you click
on Metrics, you're
able to see the request counts
and the response latency
is which will guide you through
the request and response.
And if you click on
Diagnostics, that actually
takes you to the trace.
So now if I want to drill deeper
into the 95th percentile, which
is probably the one I want
to look at because it's not
performing very well,
then I can click on that
and see a specific request why
it was slow, for what reasons,
and which requests
were actually slow.
So in this case, we can see
that the checkout service was
a little bit slow
in send and receive,
so we may want to
delve deeper into that
and find out what's
going on there.
So the Diagnostics tab
and the Metrics tab
are really good friends
for troubleshooting.
STEPHANIE WONG: Great.
And at some point,
you probably need
to dig a little deeper
into the services signals.
Let's say maybe you
received an SLO alert
and there's no obvious
upstream cause,
or you have a customer complaint
outside of an SLO alert
that you need to investigate.
Or maybe you need to see how
the new rollout of your code
version is going.
How do you get a coherent
display of all the signals
for a specific service?
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Yeah, so I think
the best thing to
do at that point
is you got an alert through SLO.
You want to look at
metrics and diagnostics
to kind of figure
out what's going on,
because metrics
and diagnostics are
going to be helpful
to understand
which specific service
is not performing well.
As you can see in diagnostics,
when we drilled deeper
into a specific service,
we were able to find out
that checkout is the culprit,
and so we can drill deeper
into that.
So those metrics and diagnostics
would be your great friends
in order to find out
what's actually going on.
STEPHANIE WONG: So
Stackdriver Service Monitoring
gives you a whole new way
to view your application
architecture, reason about
its customer-facing behaviors,
and get to the root of
any problem that arises.
So thank you so much,
Priyanka, for showing us
how Google is transforming the
ops experience of Cloud native
and microservice deployments.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Thank you for having me.
It was fun.
STEPHANIE WONG: Time now
for our next DevByte.
If you want to learn how to
build amazing apps with Cloud
Firestore, check this out.
NATALIE VAIS: Let's say
you want to build an app.
Not just any app, but
a serverless, scalable,
mobile, syncing,
analytical, IoT app.
If you do a quick
Google search, you
will get 1.2 billion
results on how to do this.
So where do you start?
My name is Natalie Vais,
and I'm a product manager
on Cloud Firestore.
Today, I want to talk to you
about building amazing apps,
specifically how
to build globally
scalable apps with
Cloud Firestore.
If you're starting a
new project from scratch
and you want to
build it yourself,
you'll likely have to think
about a couple of things.
Number one, setting
up a database.
Number two, creating some kind
of API layer on top of it,
so you can make queries
from your clients.
And that probably means third,
creating an authentication
service to make sure
users can only access
data they're supposed to.
And then lastly,
making sure your data
syncs with your
local results, which
are probably being stored in
a completely separate client
database.
Now, just make sure it works
across multiple platforms
and can easily handle
things like spotty network
connections.
Simple, right?
As soon as your app goes viral--
fingers crossed for you--
all of a sudden you have
to worry about scaling,
high availability, and
disaster recovery strategies
and you'll probably need to hire
more people to manage it, too.
Or you can just use
Cloud Firestore.
Cloud Firestore is
a fully managed,
serverless, NoSQL
document database,
purpose built for solving
some of the toughest
problems of mobile, web, and
IoT app development today.
In many ways, it's
more than a database.
It's an entire back
end for your apps.
To create Firestore,
we learned from two
other popular databases at
Google, Firebase Realtime
Database and Cloud Datastore.
Usage patterns have shifted
since those architectures
were designed some 7 to 10
years ago, respectively.
So we took a close look at the
developer wish list for each
of these to inform the product.
You can think of
Firestore as the best
of both of these worlds.
Cloud Firestore
handles all the things
that you don't want
to think about when
you're developing a mobile app.
So you can really focus
on your core business.
The first thing to know is
that Cloud Firestore is fully
supported in the Firebase SDKs.
This includes web,
iOS, and Android,
so you can access data
directly from these clients.
This works in conjunction with
Firebase Auth and Security
Rules.
And those things
allow you to control
who has access to read and
modify data on the server.
There's that off layer we
mentioned at the beginning.
You wouldn't believe how
normal it has become for people
to look at their apps
when there is absolutely
no chance of connectivity.
A person checks their phone an
average of 80 times in a day,
so it's becoming increasingly
common for people
to expect our apps to work
offline and across devices.
With Cloud Firestore,
the client libraries
already come with full
support for offline mode.
The SDK handles conflict
resolution on device
and syncs up with the
server when you reconnect.
Because we built Cloud Firestore
with a serverless architecture,
you don't have to worry
about provisioning, capacity
planning, scaling,
or maintenance.
There are servers
distributed across the world,
just not ones that
you have to manage.
All of this is taken
care of by the system.
Scaling is automatic and
happens as an online operation.
Say goodbye to
maintenance windows.
On top of that, Cloud Firestore
is built for the Cloud.
That means it's replicated
across zones and regions
depending on how you
choose to configure it.
In this year alone, and as part
of going generally available,
we added 10 new locations
to Cloud Firestore.
Replication across
data centers is really
one of those things you want
to outsource if you can.
It becomes complicated
quickly and is
a huge overhead for ops teams.
With this replication, you get
five-nines SLA for multi-region
and a four-nines SLA for
regional deployments.
This is one of the highest
availability services we offer.
All of this lets you focus
on your core business
and leave the infrastructure
to Google Cloud, which
is our core business.
With over 1 million
databases created already,
Cloud Firestore has
seen a huge diversity
of workloads already deployed
within our customer database.
The unifying themes
among these workloads
include number one, the
need for data access
even when connectivity
lapses, number two,
scalability for many
users across platforms,
and number three, the
ability to move quickly
from prototype to production.
And that's Cloud Firestore,
your autosyncing,
autoscaling database
in the cloud.
Give it a try, and find out why
it's the most discussed cloud
database on Stack Overflow.
STEPHANIE WONG:
Thanks so much, team.
Stay right here for more
sessions on all six livestream
channels.
After the sessions, join us for
a chat with security product
manager Rae Wang about
building secure environments
with Google Cloud.
This is the Next Live
Show coming to you
from the heart of San Francisco.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
RETO MEIER: Welcome back
to the Next Live Show.
I'm Reto Meier.
STEPHANIE WONG: And
I'm Stephanie Wong.
Joining us now, Rae Wang,
security product manager
for Google Cloud.
Thanks so much for joining us.
RAE WANG: Thank you.
It's great to be here.
STEPHANIE WONG: So security is
such a vital part of everything
we do online and in the cloud.
Let's talk about
security at scale.
As our environments grow larger,
security simply must keep up.
How is network
security changing as we
move from brittle environments
built on static IPs used
to microservices?
RAE WANG: Yeah, the traditional
IP-based networking policy
requires a very
detailed knowledge
on the nitty-gritty parts of
your networking configurations.
They don't really offer you
a concept of which service
can talk to what unless you
segregate them by IP addresses
and subnets ahead of time.
And this quickly
becomes unwieldy, right?
As you scale your
infrastructure,
especially as you introduce
the concept of microservices.
And this is where a
cloud-native platform like Istio
or the managed version, CSM,
give a very different kind
of experience.
They allow the admins to
define high level policies that
focus on application
requirements of business logic.
The microservices are backed
by namespaces, which give you
a natural isolation
boundaries, and each service
is also given a unique
Istio service identity.
Then you can set policies
leveraging these identities
and boundaries.
For example, you can set
to be zero trust by default
between the services, so
that any communication will
require explicit policies.
And then mutual TLS is
enforced by default.
And once you have
configured the policies,
CSM can allow you to centrally
manage and monitor and control
service-to-service traffic and
alert on any policy violation.
So this is how whether
microservice focused a platform
like CSM, it's much
simpler to both create
and do ongoing monitoring of
network security policies.
RETO MEIER: So how does moving
into a hybrid cloud environment
impact security?
RAE WANG: Yeah.
So moving to hybrid
environment, especially
with a product
like Anthos, right,
means you now have a consistent
control plane between on-prem
and cloud.
It gives you a single
admin experience
in a single pane of glass, which
makes it much simpler to have
central visibility and control
across the hybrid deployments.
And then you can
also start using
some of the Google
Security capabilities,
even for your on-prem workloads.
For example, products like
binary authorization or Anthos
config management now
work for on-prem as well.
And of course, another benefit
of using hybrid platform
is that helps your workloads
to get cloud-ready, right?
Because containers are
portable and the admin
experience the same.
So when it comes
time to migrate,
it's a very
straightforward process.
And of course, once your
workloads migrate to cloud,
we can offer you
additional security values,
things like shielded VMs,
or zero downtime patching
through live migration,
even when there are really
big hardware vulnerabilities
like Spectre and Meltdown.
STEPHANIE WONG: You mentioned
security consistency.
What are some of
the best practices
to ensure a security
baseline with consistency
and reproducibility for all of
your resources in the cloud?
RAE WANG: Great question.
We know that security is kind of
a shared responsibility, right?
We do our part, and
customers do their parts.
So in a platform, we offer
a lot of security capability
so that customers can start
on a much higher baseline.
But at the same time,
we also make sure that--
we also want to make sure
your part of responsibility
becomes easy as well,
and that's often
done through templatized
deployments, central config
and policy management,
an ongoing monitoring
and learning.
So then in terms of deployments,
by using Kubernetes style API,
you can express
your configurations
as declarative templates.
And those config
management gave you
a central source of
truth for these templates
and allow you to deploy
the config and policy
updates by GitOps and
[? CSC ?] best practice.
These changes then get
deployed across all
of the clusters and
measures in the environment
to ensure consistency.
And then when it comes
to constraints, a couple
frameworks-- gatekeeper, policy
controller, and Forseti Config
Validators that we are
developing the open source
with communities,
they allow admins
to standardize
configurations across
your entire organization.
You can, for example,
set guardrails
by presubmit checks in
your release pipeline.
So that misconfiguration
can't even
get into the deployment process.
And then in case drift
happens in production,
you can also set alerts
and then get notified.
For monitoring, we also have
Cloud Asset Inventory and Cloud
Security Command Center.
They give you a central
view of the state of all
of your resources in
production, and then
can notify you of changes and
risks and security findings
and so on.
So together, these
tools help you
through the lifecycle of
managing your security config
settings.
RETO MEIER: That's fantastic.
Can you talk a little bit
about declarative configs
to make security controls
consistent across scale
diverse environments?
RAE WANG: Yeah.
So we all know one of
the most costly mistakes
an admin can make is
misconfiguration, right?
It's almost far too easy to
accidentally set your IAM
controls to be public or make
your network configuration
to be way too permissive.
And when you do that, you open
up your sensitive resource
to attacks and data leaks.
So this is where declarative
config makes a difference
because it helps the admin to
focus on the end goal, the end
state.
And then allow to offload the
intermediate orchestration
and workflows and
keeping up consistencies
related to the platform.
And then when we do that
across a lot of resources,
across many clusters
and measures,
we basically achieve
reproducibility and recovery
from drift, and therefore
they reduce the complexity
of applying security controls.
And they also make
it much easier
to share security best
practices because you can
deploy templatized solutions.
STEPHANIE WONG:
And not only is it
important to declare
security configs
across your environments, but
also monitor inevitable risks.
So we have a big launch,
as you mentioned,
Cloud Security Command Center.
How do we help
customers get visibility
into risk in their environments?
RAE WANG: Yeah, we're very
excited about Cloud Security
Command Center because it
kind of unifies the security
detections from Google,
together with a lot
of the key third
party detections
for the main essential
place, and really
help the admins to build them,
analyze them, and take actions
in place.
For example, one
of the capabilities
is Security Health Analytics.
It scans and detects over
20 common vulnerabilites
from publicly exposed
storage buckets to,
we talk about overly
permissive firewall rules,
to misconfigured Kubernetes
clusters and so on.
Similarly, you have
Cloud Anomaly Detection.
It automatically detects
some of the key threats
from cryptojacking
to exposed service
credentials to outbound DDoS.
And then with this GA release,
another benefit you get
is now Cloud SCC unifies
security findings
from a variety of
Google Cloud products,
from event threat detection
to binary authorization
to cloud asset inventory
to [? XT ?] and so on.
How you can use it?
Well, if you're
in a press company
and you have a
finance department,
for example, that
stores credit card
information and
sensitive, personal data,
you can use Cloud SCC to
scan the infrastructure used
for storing these sensitive
information, identify
any vulnerabilities, as well
as finding active threats that
are targeting these
vulnerabilities.
And then there's
a lot of findings.
So we give you a way to manage
and organize these findings
by attaching a business
context to the findings
and the resources via
[? atcote ?] security marks.
And then we all know
that getting the data
is the first step.
What you really want to do is
to improve your security posture
from the data.
So Cloud SCC also allows
you to actually respond
to take actions by, for example,
triggering alerts or creating
IARM instance or directly
executing remediation
operations via Cloud Functions.
STEPHANIE WONG: Great.
Thanks, Rae.
Your insights into
security will continue
to be vital to any company
that wants to build and grow
quickly.
RAE WANG: Thank you.
RETO MEIER: Now, over
the last three days
we've brought you amazing
demos from our showcase.
But guess what?
There is so much more.
Here are Natalie and Mark
to take us on a tour.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Welcome to the
Google Cloud Next 2019 showcase
floor.
NATALIE PIUCCO: We're
super excited to take you
around all the different
demo areas and neighborhoods
that we have around the floor.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: There's
lots of cool stuff down there,
so why don't we show you around?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
NATALIE PIUCCO: Oh, what?
MARK MIRCHANDANI: There's
so much great stuff here
at Google Cloud Next 2019.
We've only begun to scratch
the surface with the showcases
we've shown you, and
there's tons of people
here with high energy.
NATALIE PIUCCO: I know, right?
I think there's roughly around
30,000 people or more here,
actually.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Crazy.
NATALIE PIUCCO: Lots of
amazing demo stations
where you can learn about
our Google Cloud Platform.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Yeah, it's super cool,
but if you weren't able
to see it for yourself,
don't forget to check out
all the content on YouTube,
so you can see us showcase
some of these demos
but also see some great talks.
NATALIE PIUCCO: That's right.
And we're looking forward
to seeing you next time.
RETO MEIER: Thanks very
much, Natalie and Mark,
for those highlights.
Now, we want to share a fun
competition that happened here
at Next.
Earlier this week in our
[? Gibson ?] Theater,
we got to see how heroes
are made in the Cloud.
NATALIE PIUCCO: Cloud
Hero is a hackathon
where players test their
knowledge of Google Cloud
through timed challenges.
The challenge is built on an
entirely serverless system
using Angular, Cloud
Firestore, and Cloud Functions.
Thank you to all
our participants,
both here at Next
as well as online.
RETO MEIER: All right,
it's time to step away
for the next session, and
afterwards, Stephanie and I
will be back to wrap things
up here from Next '19.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Well, it's a wrap.
On behalf of the
Next Live Show crew,
thank you for hanging out
with us the last three days.
STEPHANIE WONG: We had a great
time sharing the Google Cloud
Next '19 experience with you.
RETO MEIER: But it
doesn't end here.
Everything we've livestreamed--
the keynotes, the recaps,
the Next Live Show experience,
and all the sessions at Next
will be available
to watch, share,
and re-watch on our
video-on-demand page
at g.co/nextonair.
STEPHANIE WONG: Next '19
is about to go global
as it heads to Tokyo and
then London later this year.
Follow us at g.co/cloudnext
to stay in the know.
So long, from San Francisco.
RETO MEIER: Thank you
so much for watching.
STEPHANIE WONG: And
we'll see you next year.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]